tens of thousands of American
servicemembers in Asia faced a growing
threat from North Korea dictator Kim
jong-un has carried out nearly a dozen
missile tests at the beginning of the
year about 28,000 American troops are
stationed in South Korea Norah O'Donnell
is on assignment in Seoul with a look at
the threat and the approach of South
Korea's new president moon jae-in nor a
good morning hey good evening to you
Charlie that's right with this new South
Korean president he is making a lot of
news promising to shake things up just
take a look at the the front page of the
paper here president moon is now
promising dialogue with the north that
puts him at odds with President Trump
raising a lot of questions about what
the two leaders can achieve at next
week's White House summit it's the
hospital here here in the heart of Seoul
lies Yongsan army garrison the u.s. is
largest military base in South Korea and
what's the total population of young
sons the total supported population is
nearly 22,000 we toured the base today
with garrison commander Colonel Scott
Peterson who said they're ready for
anything
is it true that every family has a gas
mask they have protective equipment it's
right so every family that comes through
children have special ones designed for
them spouses as well the threat from
North Korea is growing
Kim jong-un is stepping up not only his
technical capability but also the pace
10 missile test just this year
what good options are there it's called
the land of lousy options john deloria's
a professor at Yonsei university in
Seoul and an expert in North Korean
affairs does North Korea have the
capability to launch a nuclear weapon we
have to assume they can launch a nuclear
missile not ICBM but they can put a
warhead on a missile and hit targets in
South Korea and in the region under
threat 28,000 troops in South Korea more
than 50,000 in Japan and more than 6000
in Guam doesn't Kim Jong hoon want to
test an ICBM so he can send a message
that he could strike the United States
is stopping the ICBM is going to be
really tough recently there have been
more signals North Korean statements
where we're going to do it soon it does
look like this is in the immediate
playbook for what they want to do and
here's what's really interesting Kim
jong-un hoon in his New Year's speech
said that they were in the final stages
of getting ready to test an ICBM the
Director of National Intelligence in the
US dan coates
he's told Congress he does expect North
Korea to test an ICBM just this year so
that raises a lot of questions about
president moons strategy he's promised
the people here of South Korea and the
world that not only is he going to
denuclearize the north in his words but
also he's going to seek a peace
agreement with the north that of course
has been an elusive goal since the end
of the Korean War 64 years ago Charlie
nor O'Donnell in Seoul thanks Nora